ومشاهدينا معنا في الاستوديو الان الفنان
سامر المصري بنرحب فيك سامر نورتنا في
صباح العربيه المميز هذا النهار دائما
شكرا كثير لاستضافتكم بهذا اليوم الجميل
الاحتفال بمناسبه مرور 20 سنه على هذه
القناه الجميله اللي تحولت يعني عنصر
اساسي بحياتنا الاعلاميه والفنيه
كتير كتير تطورات
واشياء صارت بخلال عشرين سنه في عالم
الدراما انت طبعا لك حضور على الشاشه من
سنوات طويله اكيد شهدت هذا التغير ولمحته
يعني
ولمسته لمس اليد من طبيعه عملك يعني قناه
العربيه اصلا يعني
عم تعمل فولو ابو ابديت مع كل الحاله
الدراميه العربيه خلال اللي عم بتصير عم
نشوف تطور يعني نحن
ودعم لنجاحاتنا بكل مستوياتها يعني الزمن
تغير الجيل تغير كل شي تغير
والعربيه مواكبه لكل هذا الشيء عم تتطور
معنا
المذيع ولا الممثله ايهما افضل شغل ههه
والله هو لا هو العالم لما دخلت اليوم
لعندكم على الاستوديو عملو العاده
فتره هلا مثلا على حصان لا طالع على
الحصان نركب زين مدري شو صحراء اطلع ساعه
ونص على التصوير رد ارجاع سيارات مدري شو
انت هون ما شاء الله كتير مرتاحين يعني
سامر المصري خلينا نتكلم بالعشرين سنه
دائما ما كانوا يقال بانه الفن في شلاليه
وهذا انت طبعا اليوم عامل لنا اجواء ايضا
حتى الشباب واقفين متجمعين عند فقره سامر
لكن اليوم هل الشلاليه مطلوبه ما زالت في
الفن ام انه اصبحت سلاح ذو حدين من الممكن
تشتغل مع هذا المنتج ما تشتغل مع منتج
ثاني هل الفن تغير القيمه الفنيه
والله شوف الامامه من الخلفيه نوعين في
شلاليه ايجابيه وفي شلاليه سلبيه يعني في
شلاليه قائمه على شو بيقولوا يعني
العمل يعني انا بلاقي مثلا انا كممثل في
عندي شريك مخرج بحب اشتغل معه في عندي
كاتب بيكتب لي دائما عرفت باي مشروع بفكر
فيه
يعني نحن في شلاليه جديده طلعت
بحياتنا ببدايه الحرب السوريه خلينا نقول
عرفت طلع في شلاليه
الطائفيه اقليميه الى اخره وعم نشوف موقف
سياسي
الى اخره
اذا بتقعد بتبحث فيها بتلاقي في شلليات
لما بتشوف مثلا انت بس اسال حالك انه هذا
الممثل ليش ما هذا المنتج جابه ولا عمل
خلال عشر سنين
يعني بالكواليس
فقط
عن متغيرات حكيت عن كتير اشياء يعني
الانسان دائما بحاجه لقصص باي شكل ممكن
توصله كيف بتشوف انه ممكن
السينما تضلها مواكبه الطريقه اللي مبرمج
عليها الجيل الجديد
اللي هي قصيره
الانتباه قصير وخيارات كثيره اكيد الجيل
الجديد يختلف تماما عن جيلنا والجيل سبقنا
الجيل الجديد له له مفاهيم له يعني في
عناصر معينه بالمشاهده بتجذبوا في عناصر
انا مثلا ابني ورد كنت تكون عم اتفرج على
مسلسل عربي تعال اتفرج معي
رايح عنده على
يعني ما بيعني هذا الشيء فكنت جيبه غصبا
عنه لحتى
الدراما مشان هيك انا برايي انه لازم
تتطور وهي تطور خاصه عبر قناه ام بي سي عم
تتطور مع ما يلائم الجيل الجديد
انا كنت عجيب باب الحاره هلا صرت لؤي
بستلتو
فكتير فرق شاسع بين هذاك الفكر والكونتين
وبين هذا الفكر والكونتين انا الصراحه
يمكن اول مسلسل
بيشوفوه اولادي هو
بالنسبه
الى اخره وهذا التطور لازم كثير ناس تشوفه
في ناس طبعا حاربته وقالت انه هذا الشيء
لا هذا تسخين انتم لازم مو كل شيء لالكم
كمان انتم لهلا
بالجيل
العتيق خلينا نقول يعني كمان في جيل جديد
نحنا لازم نقدم له محتوى يلا
هل الجيل يتقبل اليوم دائما ما بيقولوا
انه والله لا اي مسلسل يعرض اذا كان الفن
هو مراه المجتمع اي مسلسل يعرض خبايا هذا
المجتمع اصبح نشر غسيل لا المفترض انه
الشاشه
لهذه المحظورات هل هذا موجود الى الان
بالعكس العالم كله يعني يتواطئ مع بعضه
فيما يخص الفن لما الفن بيتطور بيتطور مو
ببلد واحد بيتطول بالكره الارضيه كلها نحن
انتقلنا عالميا من اكثر من ست سبع سنين من
مرحله اللي انا بسميها التمثيل الى مرحله
الواقعيه اصبحت الدراما في العالم كلها
اكثر واقعيه فصار عليها ضروره انها تنبش
في في المخفي والمستور والاشكالي واللي ما
كان قبل يقتربوا منه دراميا ككونتد
وكمحتوى فالدنيا كلها تغيرت لما انت عم
تشوف البلاد فورز عالميه عم تفوت باكثر
المواضيع اشكاليه واكثر الطرق الشائكه في
في المحتوى الفني فما فيك انت عربيا تضلك
بعيد عن هذا التغير
عن هذا التغير
من ضمن الشغلات اللي تغيرت وخصوصا انه صار
في عليها اكبر مع ظهور المنصات الفي او دي
مثل شاهد ونتفليكس هي موضوع المواسم
وطبعا هو مش اشي جديد لانه كنا نشوفنا باب
الحاره واحد واثنين وثلاثه واربعه يعني
الى غايه الان هل هذا الشيء بيخدم الدراما
ولا ممكن بعد فتره يحرق لما يزيد يصير في
مواسم كثير وما في هذا التجديد هذا اشي
بيحرق العمل كله من الموسم الاول
بالعكس يعني انا واحد من الناس اللي انا
سعيد جدا انه طلعنا بالمحطات العربيه
وخاصه ام بي سي انه خارج هذا الاطار
التقليدي تبع انه المسلسلات كلها محشوره
في شهر واحد والى اخره قصه المواسم رائعه
جدا اذا بتشوفي انت اللايف اوف ستايل تبع
الناس كلهم ما بيقدروا يتابعوا المسلسل
اذا كان في توقيت معين كلهم بحاجه انه هن
يشوفوا على وقتهم
امتى ما بدي بخلص بقعد بحط البوب كورن
تبعي بقعد بعمل بشوف المسلسل المفضل عندي
بالعكس هذا صار
اساسي من اللايف تبع الناس بهذا العصر
ولازم يكون في سيريز كتير موسم اول وثاني
وثالث وكذا حسب النجاح هاي حسب النجاح هاي
ما لها علاقه
اكيد طبعا
انا بشوفه احيانا رخيص من المنتج انه هو
المسلسل خلص ولسه بده يمدده طب مش مرات
بستنفذوه يعني كمان هلا قلتي بستنفذوا مش
ما كمان مرات بستنفذوه بانهم بقعده وحده
بتخلص انت عشر سنين من العمل والتصوير
والكتابه دفع فلوس نحن عم نشتغل للمشاهد
يستمتع حقه يشوفوا بساعتين حقه يشوفوا خمس
دقائق طب المنتجين صناع الدراما هل هذا
شيء يعني بيفكروا فيه هل انحكى فيه يعني
هلا انحكى فيه ولا ما انحكى فيه هلا هذا
عم بيصير عرفتي كيف عم بيصير بالواقع عن
طريق شاهد عن طريق عرفتي يعني كل
هالبلادفن طالعه جديد فعم بيصير والناس عم
تستمتع فيه وانا بعرف شخصيا من كل العالم
وين ما بسافر وين ما بيجي الناس مستمتعه
بهذا النموذج الجديد من السيزونز اللي انت
بتقدري تشوفيه انت ما بدك ايمتى راح تكون
بطوله مشتركه بيني وبينك في ابو جانتي هلا
شكرا جزيلا سامر المصري
العقيد كل الاشياء